il annonce les premiers prix prix du
plateau primaire assiette l'on croise
les doigts et libération c'est quand ils
ne votent non quoi lasser
c'est énorme c'est la coupe du monde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est 5h30 d'épreuves rien de prêt on
arrive avec toutes nos caisses notre
matériel juste nos légumes épluchés nos
recettes dans la tête mais les thèmes
ont aussi moins avancés take away autour
de la tomate entrée plat dessert merci
je vais refaire de l'emporter mais on
veut garder aussi notre savoir l'art de
la table à la française a fallu un mois
pour avant de trouver la bonne recette
un jour
j'étais au bout de ma vie sur cette
journée je fais dans la journée je sais
plus combien décès autour de la tomate à
un moment je prends les tomates les
couper en deux fin janvier la peau je
les coupe en deux j'arrive les pépins je
les pose sur une plaque d'huile d'olive
sel un peu de piment d'espelette et je
mets ça au four arias je vois cette eau
matelas posé sur une plaque et ça
faisait une forme un petit peu galbées
comme les oreilles gettin better et la
gambas j'ai dit balla là on va prendre
la gambas qu'on va la farcir
est un haut lieu que ce soit une patte
mon orgue et istres à la tomate dépilage
donc je commence à le faire puis sur m
c'est pas trés pas très sexy l'achever
mais attends si tu en prends deux ça va
te faire la tomate farcie donc le jury
thèse en nous et
on dirait que c'est bon ça c'est pas
beau il annonce les premiers prix prix
du plateau primaire assiette l'on croise
les doigts en argent là il annonce le
danemark alors là
on attend parce que tant qu'on n'a pas
donné votre nom ça peut être encore une
autre et qu il à libération c'est quand
une boîte non classé
c'est c'est énorme monsieur paul voilà
c'est la coupe du monde
[Musique]
c'est important pour nous de pouvoir
rattaché quelque chose enfin cette
gastronomie à la frange moi c'est des
valeurs de
public de transmission on a un
patrimoine j'ai mangé à
à singapour dans un restaurant qui est
suédois qui aujourd'hui trois étoiles
qui vient d'avoir trois étoiles manger
des crêpes suzette c'est pas les
meilleurs crêpe suzette que j'ai
mangeons en attendant elle été fait là
bas alors que nous on s'interdit de le
faire c'est quand même dommage on a tout
un patrimoine qui est exploité dans le
monde entier que les gens s'approprient
et nous on quelque part on en a honte
parce qu'on nous dit ça fait ringard en
fin de compte
il n'y a rien de ringard dans tout ça
c'est garderont ce qu'on a essayons de
le remettre en place et de nous leurrer
appropriée à fierté mais pas d'arrogance
il ya beaucoup de choses que les gens
s'approprient maintenant on doit se le
réapproprier et on doit le mettre en
avant ses dix patrimoine là moi qui
m'intéresse
[Musique]
pour moi il faut comprendre il n'y a pas
qu'une seule et quand vous faites un
apprentissage pour moi c'est ça doit
être aussi bien valorisé que le gars qui
va faire l'école de la république c'est
toutes ces écoles la transmission et
c'est pour moi ça a été quelque chose
d'important dans tout au long de ma vie
j'ai eu la chance de croiser des gens
qui m'ont transmis qui m'ont appris des
choses qui m'ont montré des choses la
transmission c'est pas un mort un gars
chez les tailleurs de pierre par exemple
avant les premiers tailleur de pierre
c'était un meilleur
un burin et puis un maillet on est happé
tu là aujourd'hui vous avez des
nouvelles technologies vous avez dû
mécanique qui vous permettent de taille
et la même chose mais on est dans le
mécanisme tailleur de pierre quand ils
apprennent à tailler la pierre ils
apprennent les deux techniques qui nous
sont notre charte de meilleur ouvrier de
france et aussi ça c'est essayer aussi
de transmettre aux jeunes générations on
leur donne l envie d'aller faire ce
qu'on coin
l'excellence et c'est quelque chose qui
me tient à coeur parce que
pour moi quand on fait quelque chose
c'est soit on le fait avec le coeur et
on a envie d'y aller on y va à fond
soit on le fait par j'ai toujours eu
envie de gagner des images n'est ce pas
ce que pour moi c'était
il n'y a pas une revanche sur la vie
chose que je n'aime pas trop parler mais
c'est vrai que mon donneur génitales
j'aie jamais connue voilà et
c'était ça m'a donné une force on soit
en
en disant avoir je vais te montrer avec
maman et moi on va réussir à faire
quelque chose et on n'a pas besoin de
toi